[Musik]
chaos am flughafen in kabul
tausende stürmen das rollfeld auf der
flucht vor den taliban lassen sich
verzweifelt auf tragflächen und turbinen
evakuierungsflüge von us maschinen
werden zeitweise ausgesetzt das rollfeld
blockiert mehrere menschen sterben
herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf spezial
tragödie debakel total versagen die
kritik am chaotischen ende des
afghanistan-einsatzes fällt vernichtend
aus tausende warten noch immer auf ihre
rettung auch durch die bundeswehr
über die dramatische situation in kabul
julia held
es sind alptraumhafte szenen die sich am
flughafen von kabul ab stehen
menschen stürmen die rollbahn es
herrscht chaos
sicherheitskräfte versuchen die
flüchtenden zurückzudrängen es fallen
schüsse
nur weg nur raus bloß nicht
zurückbleiben in einem land das sie
verloren glauben
verzweifelt klammern sich die menschen
an die gangway hängen sich an die
startenden flugzeuge
bilder im netz zeigen dass einige diesen
verzweifelten fluchtversuch nicht
überleben
angst und schrecken aber auch bei denen
die es gar nicht erst an den flughafen
schaffen sie hatten sich nach kabul
geflüchtet weil sie glaubten hier
sicherheit zu finden jetzt hat die angst
sie eingeholt wir sind gekommen als die
taliban masar i scharif übernommen haben
mein mann ist tot jetzt bin ich allein
hier mit den kindern
die sonst vollen straßen von kabul
verlassen modegeschäfte und
schönheitssalons haben bereits ihre
schaufenster verhängt bilder von frauen
eilig verhüllt über dem
präsidentenpalast wird die staatsflagge
eingeholt innen posieren die neuen
machthaber
[Musik]
schockstarre liegt über der stadt viele
mit denen wir in den letzten tagen noch
kontakt hatten sind nur schwer zu
erreichen haben ihre twitter accounts
gelöscht ihre profilbilder aus dem netz
genommen
zum ersten mal habe ich wirklich angst
schreibt uns eine von ihnen wenn sie
mich finden werden sie mich auf jeden
fall töten
währenddessen geben die taliban den
offiziellen ton vor der von jetzt an
herrschen soll fragen wir die menschen
aus kabul was sie über das islamische
emirat denken erklärt dieser taliban in
einer inszenierten pressekonferenz und
wendet sich an einen mann der wohl nicht
zufällig neben ihm steht ich bin sehr
glücklich erwidert der mann der wohl
auch weiß dass ihm nichts anderes übrig
bleibt es ist sehr friedlich die
menschen sind glücklich dass ihr hier
seid
am flughafen bleibt die lage auch am
abend chaotisch mehrere länder mussten
ihre evakuierungsflüge aussetzen die
verzweiflung wird das wohl noch einmal
größer machen
in berlin spreche ich jetzt mit dem
stellvertreter des generalinspekteurs
der bundeswehr generalleutnant markus
laubenthal namen und drüber sie waren
bei allen lagebesprechungen dabei was
sind denn ihre neuesten informationen
über die situation am flughafen in kabul
kann die bundeswehr ihren
rettungseinsatz fliegen ja man muss
sagen dass die situation volatiles in
kabul am flughafen die bilder haben das
eindrucksvoll
leider gezeigt wir haben unsere jungs
operationen in den morgenstunden
begonnen es sind gestaffelt flugzeuge
auf dem weg nach kabul die erste
maschine ist jetzt über eine stunde über
kabul gekreist und auf meinen letzten
informationen ungemein mit beginn dieser
sendung ist jetzt in das sicher
drittland abgebogen um dort nachzutanken
eine zweite wird in kürze bei kabul ein
treffen wir versuchen mit den
amerikanern die slots zu kriegen dort
runter zu gehen und dann die
evakuierungs operation vor ort zu
beginnen in beiden maschinen sitzen
kräfte die vor ort die sicherung sofort
übernehmen können die bei der
organisation der evakuierung helfen
können so dass wir flexibel darauf
eingestellt ist wir müssen jetzt darauf
hoffen dass wir bald einen slot kriegen
um tätig zu werden bisher konnten sie
noch nicht landen wie gefährlich es dann
der einsatz und wie viele menschen
sollen sie dann retten sie sehen ja dass
die lage wirklich sehr dynamisch ist man
hat die bilder aus der vergangenen nacht
gesehen wo eben viele menschen auf den
flughafen gelangt sind in blanker panik
das gefährdet den flugbetrieb vor ort
man weiß nicht ob sich dort auch
kriminelle elemente einmischen können
die amerikaner stellen die lage vor ort
wieder her dennoch bleibt sowohl der
anflug wie auch das ground handling das
aufnehmen der zu evakuierenden schutz
personen und das abfliegen natürlich
risikobehaftet das ist ein gefährlicher
einsatz dass ihr überhaupt einen so
gefährlichen einsatz pflegen müssen
liegt auch daran dass die lage in kabul
wolle offensichtlich falsch eingeschätzt
wurde woran liegt das ihrer meinung nach
aber
ich glaube das ist eine so komplexe
situation im moment die wird man im
nachhinein analysieren müssen da haben
sich viele denke ich in der situation
geirrt über alle instanzen das kann man
nicht in einem satz erklären da muss uns
jetzt darauf konzentrieren dass wir die
operation beginnen können wir sind im
luftraum wir müssen jetzt auf den boden
und dann die evakuierung der
schutzbefohlenen beginn viel erfolg
dabei danke nach berlin
die verteidigungsministerin selbst hat
uns vor der sendung abgesagt in
düsseldorf ist mir jetzt so geschaltet
die verteidigungspolitische sprecherin
der fdp frau strack-zimmermann
guten abend
nach mainz aber auch gut kanzlerin
merkel hat gerade von einer bitteren
entwicklung gesprochen die furchtbar sei
was sagen sie zum chaos in kabul die
kanzlerin hat vor allen dingen gerade
gesagt dass alles getan wird was in
unserer macht noch steht und das genau
ist das problem
es steht eben nichts mehr in unserer
macht wir haben wenn man die bilder
sieht die wirklich so erschütternd sind
und einem so nahe gehen wir haben als
freidemokraten in den letzten jahren
immer wieder bei der mandatsverlängerung
darauf hingewiesen und gefordert dass
wir eine sid strategie brauchen also was
ist wenn die amerikaner das land
verlassen und alle anderen nationen auch
eine
evaluation gefordert dieses einsatzes
nämlich dahingehend auch wie weit die
ausbildung der afghanischen soldaten
vorankommt und sind diese technisch aber
auch mental in der lage und willens ihr
land zu verteidigen und wir haben auf
keines eine antwort bekommen im
gegenteil ein kollege von mir hat noch
vor kurzem in der debatte den
außenminister maß aufgefordert doch mal
zu erklären was wäre wenn und seine
antwort war die freien demokraten
sollten doch bitte nicht so tun als ob
die taliban schon in kabul stehen würden
das heißt es wurde abgelehnt darüber
auskunft zu geben und das resultat ist
ein dramatisches
noch nach vorn was kann deutschland die
internationale gemeinschaft jetzt da
noch tun sie haben ja gerade von general
laubenthal gehört wie hoch das problem
ist nämlich jetzt erstmal zu evakuieren
das sind ja verschiedene gruppen das
sind deutsche staatsbürger sein angeles
das sind aber eben auch die ortskräfte
die wir seit monaten diskutieren all das
hätte man schon im vorfeld machen können
als der flughafen noch offen war als
noch möglichkeiten war charter maschinen
zu schicken das ist alles zu spät und
das dramatische svp war dass wir am
freitag noch informiert worden sind
darüber von der außen vom außenminister
und auch der verteidigungsministerin
dass es eben eine möglichkeit gibt sie
rauszuholen und kabul sicher sei und das
wurde jetzt alles überrannt und ich bin
der meinung die kanzlerin hat gerade
gesagt dass auch sie in ihrer
einschätzung verantwortung dafür trägt
die kanzlerin wird in den nächsten
wochen nicht mehr unsere kanzlerin sein
und deswegen bin ich auch der meinung es
muss eine politische eine politische
reaktion erfolgen und deswegen sind wir
der meinung dass sowohl der
außenminister als auch die
verteidigungsministerin angesichts
dieser lage und angesichts dieser
fehleinschätzung ihr amt rechtzeitig
zurückgeben sollten ja die frage nach
verantwortung vielen dank nach
düsseldorf
die deutsche sicherheit wird auch am
hindukusch verteidigt hieß es immer
deutsche soldaten sind in der gar nicht
an gestorben und jetzt dominic miller sl
über frust und entsetzen bei veteranen
haben sie auch den präsidentenpalast in
kabul unter kontrolle stabsfeldwebel
stefan maz kann es nicht fassen dreimal
war er in afghanistan stationiert er
fuhr patrouillen er geriet in
hinterhalte er tötete und es gab einen
tag an dem er gleich drei kameraden bei
einem gefecht verlor doch trotz allem
hatte er den eindruck dass die mission
sinn machte dass sie dem land den
menschen stabilität und sicherheit
bringen konnten nun fehlt ihm die
sprache
für mich persönlich ist das ganze
emotional nicht in worte zu fassen dafür
bin ich auch zu eng der situation
verwogen und habe da auch in diesem land
einfach zu viel gesehen um mich ja davon
freisprechen so können dass ich weder
frustriert bin noch wütend bin oder
traurig bin das bin ich alles
gesagt dass
nicht nur ihm fehlen die worte bei
bremen ringt heute thomas lagen stein um
fassung am grab seines bruders tobias
lehrstab 2011 in afghanistan bei einem
selbstmordattentat das ist kurios
versagen inliner kurs versorgen unserer
regierung
ja und ein unendliches leid für alle die
die eigentlich versucht haben
ja den taliban zu entkommen ein neues
leben anzufangen
soll nun etwa alles umsonst gewesen sein
alle bemühungen alle opfer im kampf für
ein besseres stabiles afghanistan
um sonst würde ich nicht sagen ich denke
auch mit einer kleinen sagt kann man
großes ernten ich hoffe dass irgendwo
irgendwas fruchtet und hier irgendwann
das gute darin erkennen können das was
mein bruder passiert ist das tut mir
unendlich weh das wird auch immer so
bleiben
mein bruder hatte einen auftrag den hat
er erfüllt definitiv
150.000 deutsche soldatinnen und
soldaten haben in afghanistan gekämpft
ein beispielloser einsatz aus dem man
lernen muss
ich hoffe man setzt sich im nachhinein
mit dieser mit diesem einsatz noch mal
richtig auseinander arbeitet das ganze
auf und geht in die zukunft mit anderen
strategien besseren plänen bessere
ausrüstung und vor allem mit dem
abschalten will vielleicht lohnen sich
die opfer dann doch so sagt der
afghanistan veteran war fast alles
umsonst
und in kabul bin ich jetzt verbunden mit
dem deutschen journalisten jan jessen
der noch vor ort ist wie ist denn ihre
persönliche situation im moment
wir sitzen hier in einem compound im
osten von kavo wir sind eigentlich
relativ sicher und
allerdings sieht die situation am
flughafen sehr
unruhig und chaotisch deswegen kommen
wir auch aktuell noch nicht raus weil
der verkehr ist ziemlich staudt auch
richtung flughafen und deswegen halten
uns jetzt erstmal diesen compart ein
großes problem sind plünderer die die
sicherheitslücke ausnutzen oder
sicherheitsvakuum ausnutzen was dieser
machtwechsel gegeben hat wir hatten
heute nacht eine große schießerei hier
vor unserem compound da irgendwelche
leute versucht in ein auto zu stehlen
die taliban gehen da relativ rabiat
gegen vor versuchen diese leute
festzunehmen und haben wohl im zweiten
bezirk wie wir hören schon ein gefängnis
für diese leute eigenen gerichte positiv
über 200 leute schon drin habe aber
gerade diese weise tatsächlich auch das
größte sicherheitsrisiko deswegen ist
raus wenn da nicht sonderlich service
draußen unterwegs zu sein
was ist denn die größte sorge der
menschen vor ort wir fürchtet die
taliban am meisten am meisten werde die
taliban natürlich gefüllt wie von denen
die in den vergangenen jahren für
menschenrechte gearbeitet haben vier
frauen richtig gearbeitet haben die für
ausländische organisationen oder dem
wasser auch die lisa bundes player oder
andere gearbeitet haben und da ist die
unruhe und panik schon sehr sehr groß
hören sie denn auch von vielen leuten
die sich jetzt verstecken oder die jetzt
noch in letzter sekunde versuchen zu
fliehen
ja also ich habe in den vergangenen
tagen viele kontakte gehabt mit leuten
die mir den besagten
branchen gearbeitet haben oder bei den
besagten organisationen gearbeitet haben
und die sind tatsächlich wenn sie in
kabul sind verstecken die sich in ihren
häusern und versuchen abfahrt erst mal
abzuwarten was passiert
und wie gesagt es sind ganz viele die
zum flughafen gegangen sind da gibt es
ganz dramatische szenen in den sozialen
netzwerken leute die sich an die
flugzeuge daran klammern ihnen wurde
gesagt sie seien zu hause bleiben erst
mal aber wurde ihnen auch gesagt wann
sie gerettet werden also ist völlig
offen gesagt die lage am flughafen muss
ich erst mal wohin es macht keinen sinn
jetzt ausgefahren und verkehr staut zu
beraten und da eine panische menge rein
zu kommen also wie gesagt wir bleiben
das mal hier geplant war eigentlich
heute an draußen fliegen aber das hat
sich glaube ich erst mal erledigt das
war
vielen dank alles gute für sie nach
kabel passen sie gut auf sich auf
das gespräch haben wir heute nachmittag
aufgezeichnet
das war unser zdf spezial mehr über die
lage in kabul jederzeit unter zdf heute
oder später im heute journal hier geht
es jetzt weiter mit der wiso
dokumentation
marktmacht mieten auf wiedersehen
[Musik]